الان معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري صباح الخير وليد ماذا رصدتهم
في اطار التفاعلات المتعلقه بتصعيد خطاب
نتنياهو ليس فقط الخطاب وانما الاعتقالات
ضد المتظاهرين ضده تفاعلات بشكل عام ضد
اهالي المخطوفين في
غزه الشرطه الاسرائيليه وبتوجيهات من وزير
ما يعرف بالامن القومي تمار بن كبير كانت
قد صدت للمتظاهرين تحديدا في منطقه تل
ابيب حينما حاولوا الوصول الى محور ايالون
وهو المحور الرئيسي الذي يربط كافه مدن تل
ابيب الكبرى واعتقلت عددا منهم مما دفعهم
للتظاهر في منطقه شرطه ديلوت في شمالي
المدينه بين تل ابيب ورسيه مطالبين
بالافراج عن زملائهم وجاء ذلك كله في سياق
سلسله تظاهرات اربعه منها كانت في كي
ساريا جنوبي حيفا وايضا في تل ابيب وفي
القدس الغربيه وفي بئر السبع لذوي
الاسرائيليين الرهائن المحتجزين في قطاع
غزه الذين يرفعون شعارات تطالب بالافراج
الفوري بان تعمل حكومه النتنياهو على
ابرام صفقه فوريه للافراج عنهم حتى لو كان
الثمن وقف اطلاق النار لكن هذه المره
اختلفت مواقفهم لانه غضبهم قد تاجج بعد ما
اعلنه نتنياهو
الذي انحى
باللائحه بانهم من خلال هذه المظاهرات
انما يعززون ويدفعون بحركه حماس الى رفع
وزياده الاثمان التي تطالب بها وهو ما
اعتبروه محاوله جديده من جانب نتنياهو
للتنصل من المسؤوليه وطالبوه بدل ان يطلق
الاتهامات ضدهم بان يعمل على اصلاح العطب
او الفشل الذريع الذي بيت به حكومته في
السابع من اكتوبر عندما تم اسر ابنائهم
واقربائهم في منطقه غلاف غزه ولم يجدوا
الحمايه من قبل لا الحكومه القياده
السياسيه ولا القياده العسكريه هذا التطور
سواء في تصريح نتنياهو الذي وجه لهم اسهم
الاتهامات او في موقفهم بالرد عليه وموقف
مناصريه يشير الى ان الثقه المعدومه بين
الشارع الاس تحديدا قطاعات من يطالب
بالافراج عن الاسرى الاسرائيليين والقياده
السياسيه تتعمق وهناك من قرا خطاب نتنياهو
او بيانه الصحفي امس وتصريحاته بانها
تندرج في اطار حمله انتخابيه في محاوله
لتعزيز شعبيته المتهاوي لكن تصريحات
نتنياهو جاءت بعد وقت قليل من تصريحات
وزير ماليته سموتريتش
الذي الى حد كبير كشف عما تبيته هذه
التوليفه اليمينيه المتطرفه لليوم التالي
في قطاع غزه عندما قال بانه سيكون هناك
حكما عسكريا اسرائيليا يدير الشؤون في
قطاع غزه وتصريحات نتنياهو وسموت جاءت
عشيه مؤتمر سيعقده انصاره ما اليوم
يطالبون فيه بالعوده للاستيطان في قطاع
غزه وهذا كله ياتي في وقت ي يماطل فيه
نتنياهو
ويتهرب من بحث طلب من قبل قاده الاجهزه
الامنيه وحلفائه في مجلس الحرب جانس وايزن
كت الذين والامريكيين ايضا الذين يطالبونه
بضروره ان يضع ويبين ما رؤياه لليوم
التالي من الحرب كل هذه التطورات لابد من
اخذها في سياق ان هذا اليوم وفق المعلومات
سيشهد ما تصفه الدوائر الاسرائيليه هنا
قمه يشارك فيها رئيس السي اي ايه ورئيسا
المساد والشباك وايضا المسؤول عن ملف
المحتجزين الاسرائيليين في قطاع غزه في
الجيش الاسرائيلي ورئيس حكومه قطر وكذلك
رئيس الاستخبارات المصريه في باريس وفق
المعلومات والذي يحاول سيحاول تحريك او
اطلاق المفاوضات من جديد وتحقيق اختراق
بخصوص ابرام صفقه تبادل للاسرى وسط
معلومات تسربت من خلال صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز يتناقلونها هنا بشكل واسع من انه
هناك تقدم قد حصل وان هناك ارضيه على اساس
ان تكون هناك هدنه لشهرين خلالهما يتم
الافراج عن نحو 100 من الاسرى والمحتجزين
الاسرائيليين في قطاع غزه على دفعتين في
مقابل الافراج عن الاف من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين لكن الخلافه بين حماس
واسرائيل ما زال يدور بالاساس حول طلب
حماس بان يكون هناك وقف تام لاطلاق
النيران في قطاع غزه وانسحاب لقوات
الاحتلال الى خارج المناطق الفلسطينيه ولا
يبدو ان هذا ما تفكر به اسرائيل بعد
التصريحات التي ادلى بها نتنياهو امس وبعد
ما تسرب صباح اليوم ونقلته المراسله
العسكريه للاذاعه الاسرائيليه عن ان الجيش
قد وضع خطه جاهزه عسكريه جاهزه للتحرك
بريه
نحو مدينه رفح وربما ايضا محور فيلا دلفي
الذي يفصل بين قطاع غزه ومصر وهذه امور قد
يكون لها تداعيات سياسيه كبيره خاصه في
العلاقه مع مصر شكرا جزيلا لك من رام الله
مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد العمري